the goal of this video is to help us all
estimate the actual
new coven 19 cases per day in your area
and it's based on analysis by thomas
puello he wrote an incredible blog post
on medium this is the link and i'll also
include it in the description below this
is the data that he uses to do some of
his analysis
now some of you might be thinking hey i
know the number of covid cases in my
area they're reporting it on the news
every day but that's the reported number
of cases and that's based on the people
that happen to get the test there are a
lot of people who might not have
symptoms yet or their symptoms are not
severe enough to get the test yet so the
actual cases are likely far larger than
the number of confirmed cases and we can
see that in graphical form once again
this is a diagram put together by thomas
puyo it's a screenshot from his blog
post which once again could be found
here this is all his analysis or based
off of his analysis but this shows you
what was happening in hubei province
which is the province where wuhan is
and there's several interesting things
here the vertical axis is the number of
cases and what we see in the horizontal
axis is per day and so for example we
could pick january 23rd
the yellow bar tells us the number of
confirmed new cases that day so these
are people who would have been tested
and then they tested positive and it
looks like that number is about 300. but
then we have this gray bar this gray bar
is the actual number of new cases that
day which is close to
2500 so
roughly eight times as high
now you might be saying how did they
know the actual number of cases if they
didn't test everyone well the way they
did that is when someone tested positive
they asked them when did you first get
the symptoms and if they said hey i
first got the symptoms 10 days ago they
would be included as a true new case an
actual new case 10 days before that on
january 13. so that chinese officials
were able to actually make these gray
bars in hindsight based on when people
said they first got the symptoms and
there's a lot of really interesting
information here
first of all we can see that wuhan was
shut down on january 23rd so let's draw
a line between the pre-shutdown and post
shutdown and you can see just as the
city officials were starting to see
confirmed cases the actual cases were
far higher but then they shut down the
city essentially significantly slowing
down the spread rate and a few days
later the actual cases which they were
able to calculate in hindsight start to
flatten out and then go down but even
though they were going down the
confirmed new cases continued to go up
because there is a delay you can even
see the delay right over here and that
is roughly the amount of time between
when people show symptoms and they are
actually tested
now you might be saying hey all right
this isn't too bad it looks like things
eventually became okay for wuhan but
this is because they did a very serious
shutdown if they did not do this
shutdown and slow the spread of the
virus you would have seen this
exponential growth continue and it's
also worth remembering what i just drew
this curve on this isn't the total
number of cases this is the number of
new cases per day if you want the total
number of cases at a given point in time
you would have to sum up the gray or the
yellow bars depending on whether you
want to look at actual or confirmed
cases so as of january 22nd if you total
up all of these gray bars over here as
of january 22nd you get approximately 12
000 cases while if you add up all of the
yellow bars
that is roughly only 444
confirmed cases
so before the city even went into
shutdown and this is what the chinese
doing reasonably good testing you had a
far higher number of cases than the
confirmed cases would make you believe
and as large as the ratio is on a given
day before the city shutdown between the
number of actual new cases per day and
the number of confirmed new cases per
day it's probably higher in a lot of the
geographies where we live because we're
not testing as well as the chinese did
for example
this is data once again compiled by
thomas puyo on his blog post this is
just a screen capture of it and i'm
really just giving his analysis
this shows the total test performed and
the test performed per million citizens
as of march 3rd and you can see for
example where i live the united states
is not doing so well
and so the number of reported cases in
places like the united states where we
are really just starting to ramp up
testing is far understating the number
of actual cases out there
so how do we go about estimating the
actual number of cases in our area
well once again i'm going to use
thomas's analysis we're going to be
looking at the number of debts and
estimations of mortality rate time from
infection to death and how fast the
virus actually spreads
so in other videos i'll talk more about
some of thomas's analysis but for
mortality rate it'll make the math
simple and this actually does seem to be
a pretty good estimate we can assume
that there's a one percent mortality
rate the reports are as low as point six
percent in south korea and then as high
as roughly five percent in places like
iran but it looks like the higher
numbers are where the hospital system is
being overwhelmed and then the lower
numbers at the point six percent might
not be fully accounting for all of the
mortality that will happen due to the
cases that are actually out there so
we'll assume a mortality rate of one
percent the other thing we need to think
about is the time from
infection to
death in those one percent of cases
where someone does die and to figure
that out i will look at this data right
over here
this top chart and it comes from this
link which thomas cites and i'll give
the link in the description below this
is the incubation period this is an
estimate of the time from when someone
gets infected to when they start to show
symptoms and this estimate is roughly
five days and then once you see symptoms
how long does it take to death in those
one percent of cases or whatever the
percentage is well there's varying
estimates but it looks like to make the
numbers easy we can estimate roughly 15
days
so one way to think about it is five
days from infection to showing the
symptoms and then another 15 days from
showing the symptoms to death for a
total of 20 days from infection to death
in what we're assuming the one percent
of cases
so i'll write 20
days
and now the other thing we're going to
estimate is the days to doubling days to
double this is how long does it take for
the infection to double in the
population and this is going to be
heavily dependent on what the population
is doing how dense they are how much
they're interacting but we'll look at
some of these estimates and they're in
very different contexts and the lower
the doubling rate that means the virus
is spreading very very fast while if you
have a population that's doing all the
right things they're taking all the
precaution the doubling rate will be
lower so we can look at a conservative
estimate and take a higher doubling rate
than all of these estimates it'll make
our math a little bit easier let's just
assume a doubling rate of five days and
i'm using slightly different numbers
than thomas used but it will be
indicative and you can do the same
analysis with whatever estimates that
you choose to do so let's assume
five days to double which might be
conservative especially for places like
the united states where we have not
taken anywhere near the action of a
place like a china a south korea or a
japan
so now let's use these numbers to figure
out what might actually be happening in
our areas based on the data that we are
presented with
so let's say that we unfortunately hear
on some day
that there is one death in our region or
in our city now based on our estimates
we're saying that the average time from
infection to death is about 20 days that
means that that person would have likely
contracted the virus roughly 20 days ago
20
days ago and so i'm going to make a
timeline this is 20 days ago this would
be
10 days ago
10 days
ago this would be 15 days ago and then
this would be five days ago
now it's possible that they were the
only person who contracted the virus on
that day and then they
happened to unfortunately get very sick
and then pass away 20 days later
but if we assume that the mortality rate
is roughly correct it's quite possible
that a hundred people were infected that
day the person that we know about is
that one in a hundred who actually get
sick enough to pass away
and so if we assume that on 20 days ago
that not one person but a hundred people
so the actual number of people who are
infected that day is 100 infected
that day once again because it's a one
percent mortality rate if we assumed a
0.5 percent mortality rate then we would
say all right there might have been 200
people infected that day 0.5 percent of
whom get all the way to death 20 days
later if you assume a 5 mortality rate
which would be a very unfortunate
situation but that is a mortality rate
that we are seeing in different parts of
the world then you would say well maybe
there were 20 people infected that day
when you only have one or two or three
deaths in a region that will make the
estimates more difficult but as
unfortunately we are likely to see a
larger number of deaths in various
regions that will make this these
backward estimates more and more
reasonable
now if the infection rate in the
population doubles every five days what
is now going to happen
after five days you're going to have
200 cases in your region
200 cases now these wouldn't just be new
cases this would be the cumulative total
number of cases due to those hundred now
this is actually quite conservative
because this is assuming that those 100
that were infected 20 days ago are the
only infected cases in your region there
might be other infected cases that were
infected before that date but i'm just
assuming that the hundred that were
infected that day are the only cases to
be conservative and so they double after
five days and then they'll double again
after five more days
and so you will get to 400 cases
after five more days and then you will
after five more days
you will have doubled and i can't even
fit it on the screen anymore
you're going to have 800 cases and then
that means today just by evidence of
that one death you probably have on the
order of and i can't even draw the whole
bar
approximately 1600 cases
and so this is just to be a little bit
sobering about how serious this is and
how much the data that we actually get
is actually lagging the circumstances on
the ground particularly in places like
the united states where we are barely
even getting started testing for example
in my county which is santa clara county
in california
we just had our second death
unfortunately reported yesterday and
there was another death five days before
that
now there's only under a hundred
reported cases in my county but based on
this analysis the actual number of
infected persons in my county is likely
to be at least a factor of ten more than
that and it could be as high as one
thousand two thousand three thousand
people we won't know for sure until we
can do the type of hindsight analysis
that the chinese had but this is to just
remind us how serious the situation
actually is
so the big takeaway here is to take all
of this very very seriously especially
because the mortality rate itself can
change depending on how well equipped
the hospital system can handle the
situation if we all socially isolate and
take the proper precaution the spread
rate will lower and we won't overwhelm
the hospital system and will hopefully
be able to keep the mortality rate as
low as possible
but if we don't take the precaution and
if we're just complacent because we see
this lagging data that's being reported
to us because of the lack of testing in
places like the united states then it's
very possible that we eventually
overwhelm the hospital system in the
next few weeks which would cause
mortality rate to go higher